so what does it mean to leak a draft
supreme court decision well of course
it's an attack on the judiciary and an
attack on the rule of law it's
leveraging the mob to short-circuit our
democratic institutions
is an attempt to intimidate supreme
court justices into reversing course
are we for that
well congresswoman pramilla paypal just
tweeted this quote the purpose of our
supreme court is to uphold freedom and
respect precedent not to take away
fundamental freedom for women to make
choices about our bodies and futures
and then she's an expert on the
constitution apparently then she called
on people to quote take to the streets
in other words to commit violence to
intimidate the supreme court into doing
what she wants not in this country
sorry
senator josh hawley understands exactly
what's going on here he clerked on the
supreme court for john roberts and we're
happy to have him join us tonight
senator thanks so much for coming us you
have a sitting member of congress
threatening supreme court justices with
a mob if they don't do what she wants
that seems very dangerous to me
you know what it is tucker is abortion
is religion for the far left and they
are willing to do anything to defend
that religion and to force it on
everybody else and that's why they're
willing to burn down the court as an
institution you know they're only for
the institution if it does exactly what
they say it should do and let's be clear
what roe really says what roe really
says is that the people are too stupid
to make these decisions for themselves
exactly the people can't be trusted to
actually vote and deliberate and make
tough moral choices it says oh no no
nine justices wearing robes they should
be the ones making all the decisions
that's not what the constitution says
though tucker and that's why we need to
get back to trusting the people and
actually enforcing the constitution well
exactly i mean i have really strong
feelings on the subject i would be
absolutely happy in fact i hope that we
can put this up for a vote in the united
states congress in the house and the
senate and we can determine what the
people want to do about abortion why is
that a scary option
you know it's not scary it's democracy
and this is about whether or not
democracy is going to have its day you
know supposedly joe biden believes in
democracy and yet today you heard him
and he was saying that this is too
important to be trusted to the whims of
the people i mean you mean actually the
voters the people who elected you the
sovereigns of this nation i mean that's
what we're talking about here so what
the court should do and what this
opinion does do is that it puts
democracy back in the driver's seat and
i hope the court will stick with it they
can't turn back now tucker in the face
of this pressure everyone i've talked to
today is afraid that there's gonna be
violence from the left is there a
certain point where the country normal
people even democrats say you know
you're not allowed to intimidate
the public into doing your will we have
a system democratic norms remember the
phrase and you know stop this you can't
intimidate us anymore is someone going
to say that at some point
i hope so because we are at that point i
mean the idea that you could go out
there and threaten these justices with
chuck schumer has done by name threaten
them by name over abortion and now you
see all of these other congressmen and
senators doing the same thing they're
just trying to hijack the institution to
get their religion forced on everybody
else i mean it is time for the american
people to actually have a say what a
concept the american people have a say
in their own government and their own
laws that's what we're talking about
here and that's what this fight is about
yeah some people with federally funded
bodyguards threatening others it's just
some it's unbelievable senator josh
hawley i appreciate your coming on
tonight thank you very much thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight